[Music]
Joseph Campbell said follow your bliss
follow your bliss and the universe will
open doors for you that wouldn't have
opened for anyone else and doors were
will open where there are previously
only walls to me that is like a big part
of the way that I want to live my life
now is to follow my bliss if you don't
have something that makes you feel
blissful I think that you have to go and
take your eyes and and look for ways in
which that you either are passionate
about something or that you can make a
difference in somebody else's life and I
think that the times that those things
intersect are the times for me that are
the best so if I'm doing something
that's gonna go and make a difference
for somebody else but it's also
something that I care about a lot myself
that I'm most excited for that right now
people have been asking me what's your
next Mountain we're gonna climb and I
tell them photography because I'm I
don't learn that and it's it it's
challenging to figure out how can I use
a camera and adapt it to me and
sometimes you know I've had some
embarrassing moments so when I'm you
know it's such an amateur level right
now and talking just because I've gotten
to meet some amazing photographers and
videographers and I go and talk to them
about this stuff and I'm like elementary
school student right now with it but I'm
like I know that I have to fail a lot in
the maybe the first 10,000 pictures that
I take are gonna be basically useless
but the next 10,000 might be decent and
the next 10,000 after that might be
pretty good so the quicker I can go and
take that first 10,000 that are just
probably gonna suck the better I'm gonna
be and quicker I'm gonna get to the ones
that are decent you know I want to just
maximize that time of like that early
stage failure and no you know and then
it's not even really failure but it's
just like those little learning curves
that learning pain and then eventually
it'll be pretty pretty good one of the
one of the tougher periods of my life
when I felt hopeless was around 10 years
old I started just having just fears and
doubts over what my future was going to
look
like and just not knowing right not
knowing if I'd ever be able to live in
my own if I'd ever be able to have a you
know a girlfriend someday or a job or
like any of those things if it was just
a lot of like fear in doubt and actually
I think a lot of what loosen the grip on
that hopelessness was I can look at a
couple like like two particular moments
and it was sports helped with that it
was making my first tackle in football
and it was winning my first wrestling
match in football the guy went to go and
block me had no idea how to block me I
had no idea how to like I was gonna go
and do it so he just stood straight up
and I dove under his legs and tackle the
quarterback first play I got the sack so
I've told my dad that night I think I'm
done with youth football and going
straight to the NFL now and then in
wrestling I lost every single wrestling
match for a year and a half so I lost 35
matches in a row I hated it my mom and
dad you know we're kind of dragging me
out to wrestling practices dragging me
out to matches and I wanted to go and
give up and wanted to quit and even if
you asked my dad if he thought that I
would have ever won a match he had been
a wrestler and he would have told you no
and all of a sudden no but he continued
to you know kind of push me to stick
with it and anyway he told me my dad
said you know said everybody loses their
first year in wrestling and everybody
loses every match you know their first
year he said but everybody wins at least
one match their second season because
you'll find somebody who was there for a
season so you'll beat them and so I
ended up winning my first match off of
like a seventh grade I'll never forget
just the experience of it looking at my
opponent and I could see he was a first
year wrestler and I thought like that's
my that's my kid that I'm going after
and so we shook hands and I all of a
sudden I think when you have hope you
start looking for all the evidence as to
why you're going to succeed I think when
you lack that hope then you start
looking for all the reasons as to why
you're going to fail and for this
this first match I started seeing this
kid I'm like he's he's kind of scrawny
is you know like you know doesn't even
he's not warming up the right way and
then we shook hands before the match was
like he's got a we can shut it we can
shake my brains scanning for all this
confirmation bias but like a positive
form of it to go and see all the
evidence this is why I'm gonna go and
beat him and all of a sudden I took him
down landed on top and I was like wow
this is awesome but I have no idea what
to do now and my dad told me to let him
up and end up taking him down let him up
to come down let him up and won that
first match by like a mercy roll tech
fall and that that moment in time
certainly started to loosen the grip on
some of the fear and doubt that I had
about my future of what what life was
going to go and look like for me is you
know quad amputee in the future and I
would have had no idea that life could
have turned out to be is as amazing as
ad but it that's why I think a lot about
now is what drives me is to go and reach
those 10 year olds who are currently
lacking hope
[Music]